[Musique]
bienvenue bonjour pour ce numéro spécial
développement durable paris saclay n'a
pas attendu la coop 26 pour se mettre au
vert démonstration dans cette émission
je vous emmène tout d'abord dans la z
pénale jaune de protection naturelle
agricole forestière un espace protégé
préservé au coeur de votre territoire
d'autres projets innovants sont en cours
avec la construction de bâtiments qui
agissent pour la neutralité carbone
comment est bien avec des bâtiments par
exemple où il ya un système de collecte
du rin vous avez bien entendu si on
collecte les urines et qu'ensuite on les
traite eh bien elles peuvent fertiliser
les champs vous allez voir c'est
totalement bluffant alors il ya des
projets plus classiques comme la
construction en bois et bien une
première présidence danse universitaire
tout en bois est en train d'être créée
c'est à l'école polytechnique d'autres
suivront enfin il ya la mobilité c'est
important découvrez l'application
numérique parking saclay qui permet
d'avoir accès à un réseau de bornes
électriques mais aussi à un parc de
stationnement assez important plus de
1000 places publiques privées voilà pour
ce programme 100% développement durable
il y aura aussi notre agenda évidemment
paris saclay c'est parti
comme promis je vous emmène sans plus
attendre dans cette zone protégée la z
pénates cela représente plus de 4000
hectares de votre territoire plus de la
moitié est dédiée à l'agriculture le
reste ce sont des forêts des rivières
des cours d'eau des rigoles un espace
protégé par la loi du 3 juin 2010
relative au grand paris c'est un
dispositif législatif unique en son
genre en france nous avons voulu en
savoir plus et nous avons donc rencontré
julie tissot directrice développement
durable et rse ne le paie à paris saclay
[Musique]
cette zone de protection elle a été
créée par la loi du grand paris en 2010
c'est d'ailleurs la même loi du grand
paris qui confirmait le projet de paris
saclay en temps coopération
internationale elle met un coup d'arrêt
à
grignotage des terres agricoles qui
étaient observés sur 7 sur ce plateau de
saclay dans les décennies précédentes et
donc à participe à réduire
l'artificialisation des terres agricoles
et naturels cette aide pénerf s'inscrit
dans notre stratégie développement
durable et responsabilité sociétale pour
le territoire paris saclay comme élément
essentiel est un véritable atout pour
notre territoire
sur ce territoire effectivement on sent
que tu as he is plus de 4000 ha tu n'es
ce pas ça décolle naturel et forestier
mais c'est aussi avant tout un
territoire qui vit un territoire
dynamique c'est aussi un lieu
d'innovation puisqu'on est en lien avec
les chercheurs de l'université dans le
cas d'un certain nombre de programmes de
recherche
la zone de protection naturelle agricole
et forestière c'est une charte pour
cadrer la gouvernance avec un règlement
qui est associé c'est surtout un
programme d'action justement pour
participer à animer cette zone un
programme d'action partenariale puisque
aujourd'hui ce sont 23 pilotes qui est
pilote 28 actions depuis 2017 et
jusqu'en 2023 nous faisons aussi un
travail d'évaluation très rigoureux
chaque année pour voir les bénéfices de
cette zone de protection naturelle
agricole et forestière et ce travail
permettra d'alimenter
l'élaboration du prochain programme
d'action dès l'année prochaine
alors si on en vient aux actions
proprement dit qu'on a valorisé dans ce
livret d'étape il y a trois axes le
premier axe consiste à assurer la
pérennité de l'activité agricole donc
les actions que l'on retrouve dans cet
axe définissent les conditions du
maintien d'une agriculture viable
productif dynamique concernant l'axé b
il s'agit d'assurer la pérennité des
espaces naturels à décoller forestière
donc on est sur des actions qui
permettent de mettre en place une
gestion optimisée de ces espaces de
concilier agriculture et environnement
et puis enfin donc là que c'est donc les
actions de cet axe permettent d'assurer
les liens entre ces zones agricoles
naturelles et forestières et les
quartiers urbains
c'est assez exceptionnel de se dire que
demain à 500 mètres de la gare de la
future ligne 18 à palaiseau par exemple
on sera à 500 m de la z pena pour partir
en balade à pied ou à vélo
vous l'aurez compris l'objectif de le
paix à paris saclay c'est le même que
celui de la france une neutralité
carbone d'ici 2050 alors il faut des
projets innovants comme ces bâtiments ou
un système de collecte du rin est prévu
car oui il urine peut être recyclé et
elles peuvent fertiliser les champs
alors comment nous avons posé la
question à nicolas babel fondateur des
moules ou une entreprise est spécialisée
dans l'économie circulaire
on a un immeuble qui est en train de se
construire qui va accueillir à la fois
un restaurant universitaire et un
immeuble de bureaux et c'est un immeuble
qui est sous maîtrise d'ouvragé directe
de l'établissement public d'aménagement
paris saclay et dans lequel nous allons
expérimenter la collecte séparative des
urines ce projet est né de la volonté de
la direction développement durable de
paris saclay notamment julie tissot
d'expérimenter cette collecte séparative
des urines et du coup ils ont fait appel
a évolué
collègue louise raguet pour les aider à
implanter cette solution à dialoguer
avec les agriculteurs et à dialoguer
également avec des la chambre
d'agriculture plante et cité et l'inra
et pour voir comment faire une véritable
expérimentation scientifique donc les
enjeux de la collecte séparative des
urines c'est d'une part de soustraire
leur hymne des réseaux d'assainissement
puisque les urines contient 85 % de la
zone projette et cet azote est lourd à
traiter pour les stations d'épuration et
se retrouve à la fin dans les rivières
et les cours d'eau et comment tribut à
ce qu'on appelle l'eutrophisation des
cours d'eau c'est à dire que quand il ya
trop d'azoté sacré trop d'agde cela
prend trop d'oxygène et ça tue la faune
aquatique donc l'idée c'est de d'une
part de retirer la zone des stations
d'épuration et l'autre par c'est
d'emmener cet azote dans les champs
notre approvisionnement de l'engrais
c'est à 90% de l'encré de synthèse qui
est produit à partir de beaucoup
d'énergie et notamment de gaz naturel et
si jamais on peut récupérer 7 7 urine
pour fertiliser les champs et ben on
évite de produire et d'apporter cet
engrais alors concrètement à quoi ça
consiste dans le bâtiment ça consiste à
mettre des urinoirs sans eau pour ne pas
avoir lu rinne qui est diluée par les
chasses d'eau et ensuite ça consiste à
mettre un réseau séparé dans le bâtiment
pour ramener tous aturine jusqu'à une
cuve qui va centraliser et la stocker
pour le bâtiment juste avant d'arriver
dans cette cuve on installe un filtre à
charbon actif qui permet d'éliminer tous
les polluants pharmaceutique potentiel
et 7 urines elle est stockée et elle est
prélevée une à deux fois par an par un
agriculteur qui va après les pendre sur
le plateau de saclay
concrètement sur cet immeuble on pense
on estime qu'on récoltera à peu près 20
mètres cubes d'urines parents et ses 20
mètres cubes pourront fertiliser un
hectare et demi de blé une fois que
cette expérimentation sera lancée une
pourrait étudier l'opportunité de
généraliser cette collecte et du coup de
fertiliser une part significative
des champs de paris saclay tout en
préservant les rivières alentour
autre solution plus classique utilisé du
bois dans les constructions
c'est le pari relevé par le p appareils
saclay qui a signé le pacte bois bio
sourcés avec à la clé la création de
plus de 300 mille mètres carrés de
surface plancher waouh bio sur ces sur
votre territoire et parmi les premiers
bâtiments construits en bois cette
résidence universitaire juste derrière
moi nous sommes allés sur le chantier
reportage
le pea paris-saclay s'inscrit dans la
trajectoire national de neutralité
carbone à horizon 2050 et pour cela
s'engage dans la construction bio
sourcés et la construction durable pour
cela nous avons signés fin 2020 le pacte
bois bio sourcés lancé par la filière
bois ile de france et nous nous sommes
engagés à réaliser d'ici 2024
40% à minima des surfaces de plancher en
structure bois ou en matériaux
biosourcés cet engagement il se décline
concrètement sur toutes les opérations
de la paix à paris saclay et il prévoit
que seront construites près de 300 mille
mètres carrés de surface de plancher en
matériaux biosourcés notamment en
structure bois nous travaillons beaucoup
sur l'intégration des matériaux
biosourcés et du bois en structures de
bâtiments et sur la mixité des matériaux
et c'est dans ce cadre que vous avez
derrière nous le loup est sain de la
hacker house qui est une des premières
réalisations concrètes de le pea en
structure bois
c'était un bâtiment de sept niveaux donc
rez-de-chaussée plus six étages c'était
une résidence étudiante qui est composé
de onze typologie de logements qui va du
studio jusqu'à la coloc de six personnes
donc une grande variété de l'aménagement
des logements donc on a un socle en
béton s'adresse à la ville et ensuite
six niveaux construits en bois
l'avantagent de la construction voit
c'est la rapidité d'exécution sur le
chantier par exemple les six niveaux ont
été montées en un peu plus de trois mois
et cela est possible grâce à une grande
préfabrication en usine donc toutes les
façades par exemple sont préfabriqués le
plancher les ossatures le poteau poutre
également et tout est assemblé sur sur
le chantier donc il n'ya pas de retour
je suis très peu de retouches à faire
cette résidence de calling répond à de
fortes exigences environnementales qui
avait été souhaité par la ville de
palaiseau est également l'établissement
public de paris saclay
le principe de la construction bois va
nous permettre de réaliser cette
opération dans des délais
rapides et surtout de permettre
l'arrivée des étudiants dès la rentrée
universitaire 2022 ce qui est absolument
essentiel pour le territoire pour
pouvoir renforcer encore davantage son
besoin d'accueil des études
voilà pour le bâti mais la neutralité
carbone elle passe aussi par la mobilité
et le déploiement d'un réseau de bornes
électriques partagé et une application
numérique parking saclay qui permet
d'avoir accès à ce réseau parkin sac et
permet aussi d'avoir accès à plus de
monde place de stationnement privé ou
public vacances sur le campus tout de
suite les explications dans ce reportage
depuis 2018 le pea paris-saclay
expérimente une solution de
stationnement intelligent en étroite
coopération avec les collectivités
locales parking c'est clair c'est en
fait une application mobile qui
permettent de rendre visibles en temps
réel l'ensemble des places de
stationnement qui sont disponibles sur
le territoire que ce soit des places
publiques ou privées dans des parkings
en ouvrage en souterrain ou en voirie le
pea paris saclay a sélectionné le
groupement mobility bike aulas qui s'est
chargé de concevoir une plateforme de
services de stationnement et de mobilité
en co-traitance avec deux start-up zen
clark qui est chargé de mutualiser de
rendre accessibles les parkings privés
et parkings map qui a développé un
observatoire du stationnement à l'aide
de capteurs magnétiques et optiques qui
ont été agencées sur les espaces publics
toutes ces données sont agrégées ainsi
que celle de disponibilité des parkings
privés et remonte dans l'application
mobile qui est accessible aux usagers
ainsi que sur les panneaux dynamiques
qui ont été installés en entrée de
quartier des ags de moulon et de
polytechnique aujourd'hui parking saclay
c'est plus de 1000 places superviser
dont 500 mutualisés
parking saclay encourage le report des
véhicules en voirie vers les poches de
stationnement en ouvrage ainsi mettant à
profit ces espaces pour les modes actifs
et des quartiers plus apaisé après trois
années de recherche et développement
parking saclay a démontré que de façon à
gilles il permettait de répondre à la
demande croissante et évolutive en
stationnement qui est induite par la
livraison des nouvelles opérations
immobilières c'est pour cette raison que
les acteurs institutionnels compétent en
matière de mobilité telles que
l'agglomération paris saclay et en
stationnement pour les villes de gif sur
yvette et de palaiseau ont convenu de
signer une convention de coopération
publique public avec le pea paris saclay
pour pérenniser le service jusqu'en 2024
le territoire dispose aujourd'hui d'un
véritable observatoire du stationnement
qui lui permet de mieux appréhender la
place du véhicule en coeur des quartiers
sur le campus paris saclay en attendant
la mise en service de la ligne 18 du
métro automatique
place maintenant à votre agenda vous
avez envie de créer votre start up ou
tout simplement de la booster et bien ce
qu'il vous propose une offre unique en
incubation et en accélération avec un
accompagnement personnalisé individuel
collectif un appel à candidature est
lancé jusqu'au 2 décembre alors
lancez-vous les jeudis de la recherche
venez rencontrer la scientifique marie
aline martin à l'institut des sciences
moléculaires d'orsay c'est le 9 décembre
c'est un jeudi donc et c'est à 18h ne
ratez pas non plus l'exposition paris
saclay paysage elle fait étape à l'opéra
de massy à partir du 6 décembre cet
artiste 7 regard sur dix années de
mutations urbaines économiques et
humaines sur le premier pôle
d'innovation de france votre territoire
et enfin le 29 décembre vous allez
pouvoir découvrir tous les secrets de la
toile de jouy dans le musée qui porte
son nom avec une visite avec une guide
conférencière qui vous apprendra tout ce
que vous avez toujours voulu savoir sur
cette impression unique en son genre
voilà c'est la fin de cet agenda c'est
la fin de cette émission je suis ravi de
vous retrouver pour un autre numéro
d'ici là restez informé sur le site
eps.fr à très bientôt
[Musique]